الامريكي انتوني بلينكن ان
الولايات المتحدة تعمل عن كثب مع
رجب طيب اردوغان وفق وكالة
الاناضول. انقرة ايضا نددت
اما العودة الى الهدنة او
الاستمرار في الحرب. والحوثيون
الرئيس التركي يخرج من جوه
الغاضب ويعود لمنصبه هنا يصدر
سوريا. واشنطن جاهزون عسكريا
بالمنطقة اذا فشلت الدبلوماسية
مع ايران. اعياد الميلاد تأتي
بالبشرى لاصحابها لكن بوتين يريد
اردوجان مرسوما يقضي بتعيين شاكر
اوزكان سفيرا لتركيا في اسرائيل
السويدي. وبعد اساءة المانية
للرئيس التركي تأتي الاساءة من
يعلنون مواقع في البحار المحيطة
كمناطق عمليات عسكرية. منظمة
بينما قال المبعوث الامريكي
لليمن هناك خياران لا ثالث لهما.
الازمة السياسية في العراق في
محاولة على ما يبدو للضغط على
التنسيقي وبين الطرفين والجانبين
تراوح الازمة مكانها بانتظار
انضمامها للناتو. لكن لقد وقعتم
ايها الاتراك ووقعتم في فخ
العراق يصرخ من الالم. البلد
الجريح لم يسلم اعداءه الذين
فيه قصتكم لم يتحدث اي احد من
روسيا معي انا لم اتحدث مع اي
احد من روسيا. لقد وضع الصحفي في
موقف محرج. فبماذا سترد رويترز
ويرغبون بالوساطة لحل مشاكله.
نعم انه العراق يا سادة ولكن هذه
يضربونه ليلا ونهارا. يقصفونه
علنا وبالخفاء. يعلنون عداءه
على هذه الاهانة كونها احدى اشهر
الوكالات العالمية والتي تمتاز
ان روسيا تقوم بهذا وذاك.
والحقيقة انه في اليوم الذي نشرت
ويسحب منها ثوب المصادر لتجد
نفسها عارية من المصداقية.
الخارجية التركية سفير السويد في
انقرة بسبب برنامج بثه
هم يقتحمون مقر قناة تليفزيونية
عراقية بسبب اساءة احد البرامج
مرتين وستخطئون للمرة الثالثة.
رويترز لم تقم بعمل جيد. تحدثتم
عبدالعزيز بن سلمان وزير الطاقة
السعودي ان انهالت عليه اسئلة
معها قلق الحلفاء. هدية سعودية
لبوتين. بين المزاح والجد شعرة.
الطائرات الامريكية الى المنطقة.
لذا شهية المجنون تزداد ليزيد
الصحافة بشراسة وقبل قمة اوبك
بلس يجيبهم مازحا. استمتعوا
المملكة العربية السعودية
لمحاولة تمديد الهدنة في اليمن
الجديدة. راعي الصواريخ لا يحتاج
لمرعى فالسماء مرعاه. هنا اصبحت
الجنوبية. لترد امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبية واليابان برد واحد
المناسب للرد على التصعيد
الامريكي في حدوده والذي كان
التليفزيون الحكومي عرض محتوى
وصفته بانه مسيء لتركيا ورئيسها
بمناورات عسكرية مشتركة بين
امريكا واليابان وكوريا
تجارب كيم الصاروخية مرفوضة
بالكامل. لكنهم يعلمون ان هذا
يبدي موافقة مشروطة للحوار لكنه
دوء الصدر يتحلى به اتباعه. وها
عن انيابه. لما كل هذه العجلة
فهل تنتظر ودعنا ننهي مسلسل
السويد هذه المرة. واردوغان هو
الضحية دائما. هناك استدعت وزارة
وادانت باشد لكن هل تجدي
التنديدات يا احفاد عثمان?
يقول لا. ليشعل فتيل الحرب
الجوية في سماء اسيا? مهلا هل
وقوع هجوم او حصار صيني لكن
الدليفري الامريكي لا ياتي
تركيا والسويد. نعود الى قصة
الثعلب والغراب. تقول انقرة
الرد لكم متابعينا. الاحداث
والتطورات. وزير الخارجية
للتيار الصدري. واما الخصم فالى
الشارع يلجأ مجددا وهو احد اطراف
بالمجان. هنا صفقة اسلحة امريكية
جديدة والتي تقدر بقيمة مليار
ومائة مليون دولار امريكي.
السؤال هنا ماذا يوجد في احشاء
الطرف الاخر بالامس كان التيار
الصدري. اما اليوم فالاطار
هذه الصفقة من اسلحة لجعل تايوان
تعلن التحدي. كارثة المجنون
تحترموا المصادر. الوزير لم ينته
بعد. لقد اخطأتم. لقد اخطأتم
المرة ياتي من الداخل. بعد
اعتزاله السياسي مقتدى الصدر
تايوان تتشجع وتعلن التحدي هنا
وزير الدفاع التايواني شيو
الموقف. فبعد ان اغتصب اصحاب
العيون الاجواء التايوانية ها هي
الاجابة لا تكفي. ليعود الوزير
السعودي مجددا. ولكن مع اخذه
انفسكم بانفسكم ثم نسمع صراخكم.
اما بوتين فقد جمع الحكومة
تجتمع لتتفق حيث اتفقت دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي على فرض الحزمة
هذا العزل هذا ما سنعرفه في
الفيديو القادم. تايوان تقولها
العقوبات لتعاقب نفسها وحلفائها
ولا تعاقبوا روسيا. انتم تضربون
الوفاء بالوعد اولا. ثم تعود
تركيا لتهدد السويد برفض
العقوبات. ها هي الدول الاوروبية
تلجأ لفكرة ماكرون الجهنمية
الميلاد لا تخلو من الهدايا.
وبين هذا وذاك الدول الاوروبية
بارسال ثلاثة من ابنائه تبلغ
اعمار اربعة عشر وخمسة عشر وستة
الاطلاق هو السادس خلال عشر يوما
وذلك بالتزامن مع عودة حاملة
فهل تنقطع? فلم يعد هناك فرق بين
رسائل المزاح ورسائل الجد الامير
بالشمس انه يوم مشمس. نعم من
التلميح الى التصريح. فتلك
انه سيفعل كل شيء لانهاء العملية
العسكرية الخاصة بسرعة وقام
كوتشينج. في السابق قلنا اننا لن
نكون اول من يشن هجوما ولكن الان
نعم فهو يقصد ان الضربة الاولى
ستكون الاخيرة والكافية للرد
المسيارات او اي توغل لمقاتلات
الجو ستتلقى منا الضربة الاولى.
تسمعون ما اسمع? هنا صاروخان
باليستيان جديدان ينطلقان باتجاه
في وجه الصين. امواج المحيط لا
تهدأ. وضجيج المنابر الاعلامية
الاستقرار والسيادة في تلك
المناطق الاوكرانية التي ضمها
بوتين سريعا يرقي قديروف لرتبة
الجنرال الزعيم الشيشاني يتحدث
كل هذا التقدير يا بوتين لنجد
الجواب لدى قديروف. والذي قال
من موسكو والتي ردت بقوة وذلك
بعد تصريحات البنتاجون حول الدعم
قائلا انه شرف كبير بالنسبة لي
فقد ابلغني بوتين بذلك شخصيا. ما
هيبته ولتشتيت الانتباه عن وقائع
المعركة. ووفقا لتقارير اخبارية
تقف خلف اوكرانيا دول اوروبا
باكملها الا ان بوتين يتوعد ببسط
اذا فكيف سيكون ردكم الحقيقي
يابسكوف ومن اشتعال ارض المعارك
الماكرة ويا لها من فكرة باجتماع
لمجموعة سياسية اوروبية تضم
مضاد لتحرير اراض جديدة. فكيف
ستنتهي هذه المعركة؟ الرد ياتي
الثامنة من العقوبات ضد روسيا
لكن الكرملين يقول امريكا تفرض
عشر على التوالي. لنعد الى عيد
ميلاد بوتين مجددا. فاعياد
واحد. نعم. فلاديمير بوتين خصم
واحد ويقف امام اوكرانيا بينما
بمصداقية عالية ليأتي هنا الامير
السعودي عبدالعزيز بن سلمان
الروسية ليستعد للرد على
العقوبات الغربية لكن بعيدا عن
لا يصمت. ولغة التهديد لم تعد
تجدي ليكون باب الفعل سيد
نافذة لم تنفتح في الافق حتى
الان. اردوغان يقع في مصيدة
ما هكذا تؤكل الكتف. نحن لن نرد
على هذا الاجراء بل سنترك مسألة
كان لديك اسئلة لي ولكن ليس لي
لانني لن اتحدث لرويترز حتى
الصحة العالمية عشرة الاف اصابة
بالكوليرا خلال ستة اسابيع في
الغرب. لا تأمن الثعلب يوما لانك
حتما ستندم على ثقتك به. وبين
للامور بجدية ليرفض الرد على
اسئلة رويترز. ويقول للصحفي اذا
تبدل التعريف بشكل واضح. اذا
استخدمت الصين وسائل مثل
الدولي. لتأخذنا الاحداث سهوا
الى فتى بوتين المدلل وجنديه
للصين الضربة الاولى ستكون
الاخيرة والعراق من صراع غير الى
العسكري لاوكرانيا والهدف ضرب
شبه جزيرة القرم. الرد ياتي على
نفضت المملكة غبار الوصاية من
على كاهلها? السويد تستفز تركيا
سماء جيرانه مرتعا لصواريخه. هو
الرجل ولا ندري لماذا. كيم يكشر
بوتين شموع احتفاله. وبعيدا عن
اللهجة النووية الى لغة التخاطب
بحر الشرق يؤكد هنا كيم ان
تجاربه الصاروخية هذه هي الاجراء
الشرس. نعم رمضان قديروف. بعدما
ارسل ابناءه للقتال ليأتي كرم
صحيفة نيويورك تايمز والتي كشفت
في تقرير لها بان امريكا تخطط
بوتين واوكرانيا لنصب بعدها
تركيزا عليك? هنا كيم جونغ اون
التايواني. فمن اين لكم بكل هذه
الشجاعة يا هذا? الجواب ياتي من
اربعا اربعين دولة وعزل دولي
لروسيا. فكيف ستكون استراتيجية
لتحويل تايوان الى مستودع اسلحة
لتمكين تايوان من الصمود في حالة
تواصل التقدم وستستعيد جميع
الاراضي الاوكرانية لكن موسكو
نشرت صحيفة واشنطن بوست
الامريكية عشية احتفاله بعيده.
بوتين يرد عليه بخطوة مفاجئة.
وروسيا تعلن تورط الولايات
الجهنمية وما بين الشدة والمزاح
ترد السعودية على اوروبا. فهل
به. فهل ستنطفئ امال اوكرانيا
باستعادة هذه المناطق كما اطفأ
بوتين يفخر بقطع جزء من الاراضي
الاوكرانية من قطعه الجاتو الخاص
الروسي يطفئ شموع عيد ميلاده
لتمطر الهدايا عليه من امريكا
الى اشعال شموع ميلاده. وفي عيده
السبعين سيد الكرملين يقاوم لصون
لسان ديمتري بيسكوف والذي رد
قائلا. هذا امر خطير للغاية
تقول عكس ذلك. اوقفنا تقدم
الاوكران نحو خرسون ونستعد لهجوم
مؤخرا. القوات الروسية تتراجع
واوكرانيا تتقدم. وكييف تؤكد
في اليمن الحوثيون يعلنون
معركتهم القادمة. المعركة
الاضطراب الداخلي وشروط جديدة
تقلب الطاولة وبعد انتهاء الهدنة
الحاسمة. تبدأ معركة وتنتهي
اخرى. لكن الحرب واحدة والخصم
ودليل مباشر وغير مباشر على تورط
الولايات المتحدة فيه الصراع.
وانقرة ترد وحلم المجنون يتحقق
والاعداء يجتمعون. تايوان تعلنها
ودول اوروبا. فما هذه الهدايا?
وبعد ان انجز قديروف هذه المهمة.
المتحدة بالادلة. كيف بينما
الغرب يوافقون على خطة ماكرون
ان يأتي عيد ميلاده بالنصر
لروسيا. فهل يتحقق ذلك?